the england players spent a quiet night
in rome
resting up in their hotel ahead of a
match which could take them a step
closer to becoming european champions
but when they emerged to take on ukraine
today there will be no stadium rammed
with fans to cheer them on
covered restrictions have prevented
thousands traveling from the uk
to italy but some avid supporters have
secured tickets and seats
and were able to make the journey from
their homes in the european union
the bennett family flew in from cyprus
thrilled at being able to attend this
england game
especially because the semi-finals and
final
will be held in the uk i will definitely
be screaming
i'm gonna i think i'm really gonna be
shouting she can shout
i mean like we're gonna make it up for
the fans at home who can't come because
i think
obviously there's not gonna be as many
of us so for the the few that are there
we really need to make an impact the
next
two semis and final is at wembley so
at least they've got something to see
and i'm certain england will be there
in rome's fan zone where italian
supporters celebrated their team's
victory over belgium
the number of spectators will be limited
for the england game
so too in the stadium while there'll be
checks on where people have traveled
from
england fans buoyed by the team's defeat
of germany this week might have been
tempted to hop-foot it to rome
but the warning from the authorities has
been don't do it
there wouldn't have been time to
complete the mandatory five-day
quarantine
before the quarter-final with ukraine
and the regional health chief had strong
words for anyone
tempted to break the rules
i want to tell the english fans that you
must not die for a match
i would invite them to cheer for their
team england from home
because coming here would be risky and
also
it would be impossible to enter the
stadium whilst england players admitted
they would miss the throng of the crowd
in the stadium
manager gareth southgate said the team
might actually
benefit from the match being played in
italy
i think it's good to come away from
wembley now
it would have been hard to replicate the
atmosphere we had the other day three
days later and i think to have a
different focus different surroundings
different sort of a challenge is good
for us tens of thousands will be out to
support the team
but we'll be watching from home
territory just hoping
tonight's match will lead england to
playing their next at wembley
very soon michelle clifford sky news
rome